with the legendary career spanning
nearly 60 years Jack Nicholson is
considered one of Hollywood's all-time
greats but the award-winning actor
hasn't appeared in the movies since 2010
meaning fans only get to see him when he
pops up at award shows so what's up with
the actor's disappearance well if you
think you can handle the truth keep on
watching to find out why we don't hear
from Jack Nicholson anymore his last
film was a bomb Nicholson's last film
2010 s how do you know should have been
great it boasted an all-star cast
including Paul Rudd Reese Witherspoon
and Owen Wilson while reuniting
Nicholson with terms of endearment and
as good as it gets writer and director
James L Brooks however the film was a
critical failure and a box-office bomb
earning just over 48 million worldwide
against a budget of 120 million dollars
at the age of 80 Nicholson has to really
want to be in a film these days to
bother and with his last movie being
such a disappointing experience it's no
wonder he's shied away from movies ever
since you do not have the luxury of not
hearing god are you gonna make me
literally run from bad news the board
has these memory loss long gaps between
films is actually nothing new for
Nicholson as he's gotten older he's
frequently taken long breaks between
movies while waiting for the right
project to come along with four years
transpiring between as good as it gets
and the pledge and three years between
something's gotta give and the departed
but in 2013 rumors began swirling that
his current break wasn't caused by a
lack of interest but instead by the
rigors of old age as radar Online
reported that Nicholson was suffering
from memory loss a source told the
tabloid jack has memory issues and can
no longer remember the lines being asked
of him not so fast
reports of Nicholson's supposed memory
lost immediately went viral sparking a
debate in the media over whether the
allegations were true just a few weeks
later however a pretty reliable source
came forward saying that Nicholson was
doing just fine that source Nicholson
himself yep Nicholson sat down for a
rare interview with the son and
explained that his memory is totally
fine
instead he chalked up the reason for his
absence too simple boredom with the
whole movie star thing saying he was
enjoying the retired life I'm not going
to work until the day I die that's not
why I started this I mean I'm not driven
I was driven but I'm not I don't have to
be out there anymore in fact there's a
part of me that never really liked being
out there I
enjoy it as simple as that and that
certainly has the ring of truth you want
answers I think I'm entitled you want
the truth you can't handle the truth
don't call it a comeback given its
legendary status you'd think Nicholson
would pretty much have his pick of movie
roles and you're right in just the past
few years Nicholson has reportedly
turned down offers to appear in films
like the judge 42 and Nebraska with
those roles instead going to Robert
Duvall Harrison Ford and Bruce Stern he
was also involved in st. Vincent before
recommending Bill Murray for the role
instead in his pal Warren Beatty tried
to get him the star and rules don't
apply with no luck but his acting days
might not be entirely behind him just
yet according to Variety Mickelson is
planning to return to the big screen for
a remake of the German comedy Tony
Edmond which earned an Oscar nomination
for best foreign feature of course he's
changed his mind before but here's
hoping we get to see Jack doing his
thing on screen at least one more time
and if not well considering that
Nicholson has appeared in some of the
greatest films of all time and given us
some of the most indelible roles in
movie history it's clear he has nothing
left to prove to anyone least of all
himself all we can say is thanks jack
thanks for watching click the looper I
kind of subscribe to our YouTube channel
plush check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to